und ich würde dich gerne fragen wie geht
es dir so damit oder wie siehst du das
ja es ist für mich immer ein sehr
schwieriges thema weil man möchte auch
nicht anklagend sein welche man möchte
auch nicht rumjammern
ich möchte einfach auch aufklären seien
halt nicht dass wir halt im dialog
miteinander sind zu sagen hat es ist
nicht immer einfach in dieser hautfarbe
zu sein weil man darauf reduziert wird
dass man nichts anderes ist ich bin in
deutschland geboren ich bin 50 jahre in
deutschland
ich habe mein ganzes leben hier gelebt
aber meistens wenn ich immer wieder
reduziert auf meiner hautfarbe halten
nur sei es wenn ich irgendwo einkaufen
gehen oder sah ich dass das ich im
restaurant nicht bedient werde oder wenn
ich bin schauspielerin wenn ich mich bei
agenturen bewerbe heißt es lässt du hast
so viel farbe für uns halt nicht und es
ist etwas was sehr weh tue was ist das
genau und dann muss ja damit klar kommen
und man kann gewisse leute auch nicht
erwähnen die an die die einkommen und
man sagt einfach denkt doch mal nach
seinem sensibel
wir sind eine mut- und kulturelle
gesellschaft was auch toll ist wir
können ja alle nur voneinander lernen
was ich großartig finde wie kann man
jemanden reduzieren der einfach eine
andere hautfarbe hat ich sage
integration ist für mich auch wir müssen
aufeinander zugehen weil was soll ich
noch mehr tun als die deutsche sprache
zu hören abitur zu machen ausbildung zu
machen
ich möchte hier ankommen und es soll
auch nicht falsch verstanden sein ich
liebe deutschland ich liebe dieses land
ich fühle mich hier sehr wohl
ich kenne kein land was hilfsbereiter
ist als deutschland mit den ganzen
selbsthilfegruppen an alles mögliche
aber es ist manchmal nicht einfach damit
umzugehen und ich denke wir müssen immer
im dialog bleiben
jetzt ist die geschichte mit george
freut passiert klar sitzt mir das unter
anderem deswegen zusammen aber ich
wünsche mir natürlich dass es immer so
ist dass wir immer wieder im dialog
bleiben und uns austauschen und das
vielleicht auch die ausgenommen wird wie
können wir miteinander umgehen
es ist ja auch schon so dass jetzt
gerade ab dienstag war das black tuesday
war das auch ein ganz ganz großes thema
unter anderem bei instagram ist jetzt
gerade
sehr sehr viele menschen haben schwarze
bilder gepostet oder drunter ihren
hashtag black lips mädels gepostet und
das hat eine richtige welle der
solidarität gezeigt na also dass das war
ganz ganz groß wie hast du das empfunden
wie fand sie die aktion ich war die
super ich habe es auch gemacht und
einfach nur an einem symbol zu zeigen
heißt wir halten alle zusammen
und wenn man zusammenhält geht das
manchmal ein wenig schmerzen besser
ertragen halt nicht dass man nicht
alleine ist damit dass leute hinschauen
und ich sage immer es ist die minderheit
die so denkt die größte menschen wie man
sieht die alle mitgemacht haben glauben
an was positiven an der multikulturelle
gesellschaften die die nummer sind ich
habe auch mitgemacht weil ich das
genauso sehe wie du und dennoch habe ich
auf instagram sehr viel kritik auch
gelesen und es ist so ein bisschen so
naja jetzt die die sonst immer die
klappe halten machen sie es jetzt
besonders einfach posten einfach ein
schwarzes feld und setzten sich sonst
nie ein und das hat mich sehr
nachdenklich gemacht weil natürlich
stimmt dass zum beispiel in meinem fall
ich bin keine aktivistin ich lebe ein
privilegiertes leben wenn man so will
ich bin von rassismus nicht betroffen
ich habe ein freundeskreis der welt
offen ist wo alle menschen von allen
möglichen nationen oder hautfarben oder
sexuellen orientierungen im leben ich
erziehe meine kinder als solche in so
fertig bin keine aktivistin
aber dann habe ich hatte war ich kurz
davor zu sagen na ja aber jetzt ich
möchte mitmachen um ein zeichen zu
setzen
aber ich habe das gefühl das ist gar
nicht recht und und und dann habe ich
nicht verstanden warum das eventuell
nicht recht sein könnte das schlimmste
ist doch wenn wir alle schweigen also
selbst wenn das leben ein
ja genau damit nicht machen weil genau
das diesen zwiespalt dieses gap das
verstehe ich total das war der grund
warum ich es nicht gemacht habe ich habe
es nicht gepostet und das heißt nicht
dass ich mich gegen diese solidarität
wenden möchte ganz im gegenteil die war
sensationell die war super aber ich fand
es zu einfach das thema ist zu laut um
zu schweigen und ich verstehe ich hätte
zum beispiel begrüßt wenn man gesagt hat
okay wie posten das foto wir posten gut
mit dem hashtag hat meine probleme liegt
daran dass ich finde natürlich nicht nur
das live matches ja aber das ist ein
anderes thema trotzdem finde ich einfach
persönlich dass wenn ich mich dazu
bekenne und das sollte man
auch tun ganz klar dann muss ich doch
irgendwas drunter schreibe wie du auch
gerade schon gesagt hat man muss sich
austauschen
heute sitzen wir in der sendung
besprechen das thema wir sind nicht
schwarz wir besprechen das thema und das
hat mir bei instagram so gefühlt er so
gefehlt überlegt mal mehr wie geil es
gewesen wäre wenn jeder bei instagram
dieses foto gepostet dass seine bedenken
seine ängste seine erfahrungen
irgendetwas wenn es da ausgetauscht
hätten die spieler aber ich finde es
ging ja genommen das gegenteil und ich
muss dir sprechen bei dem onlive mehr
das ist sozusagen weg live matters weil
wenn onlive matters dann sozusagen
gehört all back mit das live dazu und es
geht wirklich ehrlich aus ich finde im
moment eigentlich eher dass es dafür
zeit wird dass diejenigen die davon
betroffen sind das die mehr gehör
bekommen also das wird ja gerade auch
sehr intensiven in deutschland in die
mission gefragt denn es geht ja nicht
darum was mich zu sagen sondern seiner
solidarität auch meinem schweigen
ausdruck zu verleihen und zusagen
beispielsweise ich mache jetzt platzt
sozusagen und sorge dafür dass meine
schwarze freundin oder meine schwarzen
brüder jetzt zu wort kommen und sich
dazu äußern weil auch hier in
deutschland gibt es ja genug schwarze
deutsche die sich auch nicht gehört
fühlen sie fühlen sich nicht gehört auch
in ihrem schmerz nicht ja aber geht und
da geht es ja darum wie sie sagen der
wahllisten gern zitiert vielen willst du
er ist ja und das finde ich gerade sehr
schön beschrieben dass ihr auch
beschreibt dass das auch tun sozusagen
weiße auch gerade schwierig ist und ich
glaube auch es ist ganz wichtig dass
wirst du ja selber gleich auch noch mal
wahrscheinlich beschreiben dass wir
ausmachen also wir dürfen jetzt nicht zu
machen sondern wir müssen wenn wir hier
sitzen auch über martin luther king
leben der zu einem der gewaltvollen
themen der menschheitsgeschichte
sozusagen das gewaltfreie prinzip gegen
gesetzt hat das hat ihn so besonders
gemacht erst danach umgebracht wurden
dafür aber seine idee darf nie sterben
aber richtig aber ich glaube das ist
noch viel wichtiger ist was du sagst du
hast auch seine erfahrungen sagen wir
eine frage gehabt gerade gestellt oder
was findest du bringt einen wirklich
weiter was erwartest du von weißen
menschen und was nervt ich ich erwarte
dass man halt im dialog miteinander ist
dass man miteinander redet und dass man
einfach nicht wieso ich sagen ist
einfach so reduziert zu sagen ach ja
die ist eine schwarze so halt nicht man
redet miteinander ich bin in deutschland
geboren als ich habe auch andere themen
über die ich reden kann ich muss nicht
immer mal nach hautfarben ich hab' ich
interessiere mich für die weltgeschichte
und alles mögliche und du hast aber auch
ganz andere sachen erlebt die gar nicht
so schön waren ja ich habe viele andere
sachen erlebt ich hab's ja kurz auch
erwähnt mit der agentur die nicht sagt
ja
dafür hast du zu viel farbe oder halt
auch als in amerika da bin ich wollte
ich mit dem schiff nach new york das
waren ein traum von mir und ich gehe
halt zum schiff und dann sagen die er
für die bediensteten rechts rum und ich
denke die dienstenthebung ich bin ein
passagier und das konnten die eltern im
moment wenn man das so man ist diese
scharfen halt bekommt man ist einfach
geschockt und man hat gelernt auch damit
gewisse sachen umzugehen weil das es
bringt einen sonst um nicht man muss
lernen zu sagen okay das ist jetzt
passiert aber ich habe auch gelernt dem
auch nicht mehr so viel raum zu geben
dass ich mich schlecht fühlen weil es
meine lebenszeit die ich lebe ich kann
mich mein leben damit verbringen immer
irgendwie traurig zu sein dass mich
leute nicht akzeptieren ich habe das
problem ja nicht ich weiß nicht was das
problem ich habe gegen niemanden was ich
bin in der multikulturellen saison
aufgewachsen mein vater war diplomat da
waren so unterschiedliche nationalitäten
davon habe ich nur gewonnen ich wollte
ein beispiel genannt im vorgespräch mit
dem abfärben das fand ich ja also das
absolut niveaulos also ja ja also das
passieren konnte später damit auch genau
also es ist halt so dass leute mich
gefragt war ist nicht nur einmal
passiert sondern herbst du auch ab dass
jetzt eine ernst gemeinte frage ja wir
sind also gefragt ja genau ich habe
etwas was antworten ja ja schon ja aber
was wollen wir und wie soll ich da
diskutieren fängt man da an eben genau
man könnte institutionell anfangen man
könnte anfangen das thema ernst zu
nehmen man könnte anschauen da sozusagen
zu auf bundesebene zu verhandeln zu
behandeln dass leute die sowas sagen
auch konsequenzen dafür spüren müssen
und dass es kein keine zweite meinung
gibt entweder sozusagen bin ich
sozusagen befürworte ich den rassismus
als haltung oder ich kenne so ganz aktiv
dagegen riecht und das gemeinsam anders
geht es wie oft hast du das gefühl
passierte er so was also jetzt hast du
drastische fälle aber ist es so dass du
sagst das sind die ausnahmen oder ist es
so dass du sagst
gesagt habe ich jeden tag in meinem
leben zumindest einen kleinen moment der
mich dann also nein klar also dass ist
nicht jeden tag gott sei dank nicht halt
es ist es passiert ab und zu mal mann
ist am bahnhof krieg irgendwie blöden
spruch mit dem n wort und das kriegt man
so auf mal so kurz mit und ich manchmal
weiß ich gar nicht warum halt nicht und
ich sag dann immer noch es ist die
minderheit die mehrheit ist nicht so
nicht und das war wohl zu viel
trotzdem ist es zu viel aber es beruhigt
mich und darauf konzentriere ich mich an
erster linie nicht weil es ist ich mag
einfach nicht wirklich negativ durch die
welt zu gehen und nicht schlecht zu
fühlen und man trifft sich und
seinesgleichen und tauscht sich aus und
wir haben irgendwie alle die gleichen
erfahrungen sei es jetzt ein fußballer
oder ein schauspieler oder sänger die
erleben dass alle also ich bin kein
einzelfall auch wenn wir uns da nicht
kennen und man kommt zusammen was das
auch erlebt es ist dieser versteckte
rassismus dass man nicht akzeptiert ist
ja auch unsere zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer gefragt welche erfahrungen sie
mit rassismus gemacht haben ein
statement was wir jetzt raus gesucht
haben was wirklich auch hart ist finde
ich da ist eine frau mit einem
dunkelhäutigen partner zusammen und sie
musste sich wirklich verteidigen
folgende frage wie kannst du nur mit so
jemandem zusammen sein pass auf der
vergewaltigt ich nur er wird dich
unterdrücken
gott war das ist doch wahnsinn es geht
immer um eine gefahr aus also weil ich
sag immer jede nationalität jede
religion
da gibt es da können alle verbrecher
seien natürlich es ist nicht nur nicht
leute mit migrationshintergrund sondern
jede nationalität gibt über idioten und
menschen mit migrationshintergrund sind
auch nicht die besseren menschen also
darum gehen das ist ja auch nicht nur so
dass rassismus nur in den weißen
gesellschaften vorkommen sondern wir
haben sozusagen grundsätzliches problem
damit eine herausforderung und der
faschismus begriff ich sage nochmal die
drei feinde der der rechtsstaatlichkeit
und demokratie sind rassismus
patriarchat und klassismus und das ist
sozusagen muss ankommen in den tiefen
der gesellschaft auch bei den jüngsten
dass wir das sozusagen gemeinsam im
eigenen interesse auch widerstand
leisten ja ich finde man sollte bei den
kindern anfangen ja aber ich hätte auch
im vorgespräch erzählt er
irgendeiner stadt dann kam ein kleines
kind zu mir oder sagte dass zu den
eltern
warum ist die frau so schwarz angemalt
nicht und ich hab dann gewartet dass die
mutter sagt und die mutter sagte dass
ich auch nicht dann habe ich dem kind
erklärt dass ich aus afrika bin zwar in
deutschland geboren bin und dass wir da
alle so aussehen
[Musik]